[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESCO CARUCCI: I'm going
to show you this Systraces.
And I'm going to show
you how to spot issues.
Issues that we found
are plenty, of course,
but four were most widespread.
Yes, I would say that these
four performance pitfalls were--
basically every game at Seoul
had one, two, or three of them.
I just found myself saying the
same thing over and over again.
I said let's look at I/O
to a bunch of other people
so I don't have to repeat
myself all the time.
I'm going to go in depth
on each one of them.
I'm going to show
you Systraces and how
to spot it in your game.
That's the first one.
And this is a Systrace.
This is basically
a certain number
of cores, eight in this case.
And you can see all the
threads running in the system.
And you can see
this thread number
three, which is basically
grabbing one core.
Two is jumping from
one to the other.
But essentially, it's
grabbing one core
and hammering it while the rest
of the system does nothing.
That's how a single thread
game looks in [INAUDIBLE]..
And that is--
OK.
In the sense that if you're
making a casual game,
a single thread casual game
is the right thing to do.
I get it.
It's just much easier.
The architecture is easier.
Everything is simpler.
You don't have to look
at synchronization.
I get it.
It's a simple thing to do.
But if you're pushing the
boundaries a little bit more,
well, you have eight
cores, you're using one.
It's a matter of
performance, but as we're
going to see later, it's
not only about performance.
This is an example
of a Unity game.
I'm not going to ask you
many Unity developers
are here to ask everyone
else the same question.
That I believe there's
going to be many.
There's going to be a Unity
mean thread, a single thread,
hammering a system
just one core.
Everything else does nothing.
That's how it typically
looks like in Unity.
And that's actually
very, very simple to fix.
That's it.
Click, click, click, click that.
Nothing.
Multi-thread
rendering, that one.
Here, just click it.
It's going to make your game
run faster and be better.
It will make me happier.
And since you're
there, you click CPU.
Scanning as well, because you
don't want to scan on the CPU.
It's bad and it makes me cry.
I don't have a picture for that.
But imagine it.
Once you click that, that's how
your system is going to look.
There's going to be a
nice main thread, which
is processing you entity.
Each entity will generate
a bunch of graphics command
for the render thread that will
take these graphics commands
and in parallel,
it will generate
a bunch of rendering
commands for the GPU
which runs in parallel.
Now instead of having a thread
that is hammering one core,
you have two threads.
At least you're
parallelizing your work.
And that's how Systrace
is going to look like.
You're going to have Unity main,
which is a bit smaller, Unity
GFX device.
I don't know why W. I
always wondered why.
This is not going to give you a
double frame rate straight out
of the gate, because
you're not probably
going to have workloads that
are exactly the same time,
and can be just
perfectly parallelized.
But you see it's a
pretty decent difference.
You're going to get
something out of it.
More interestingly, you're
going to let the CPU that
is running Unity
main, have the chance
to sleep for a little bit.
We'll see why it's very, very
important to let cores sleep.
It sounds weird.
At the end of the day, you want
to parallelize your workloads
because they will give
you better performance,
but also because if you don't
do that, that's what happens,
higher power consumption.
That's a direct consequence of
having one single thread that
does everything.
It means that you're going
to consume more power,
you're going to drain the
battery much faster, which
leads us to the second issue.
This is a gigantic deal.
This is a big deal.
If there is one
thing that I need
you to remember out of
here is thermal throttling
is a big deal.
That's because on
mobile performance
it's not constant over time.
You think, I worked on console
and PC, pattern console.
It's more fun.
But once I made my frame take
33 milliseconds to process,
I was done.
I lived in England at the time.
Everyone was going to the pub.
I'm Italian.
I was having a coffee.
Please don't have
cappuccino after lunch.
It's bad.
All mobile things
are much different.
On mobile, once you render
33 milliseconds for a frame,
here's what happens.
You have your carefully
optimized game.
You give it to someone to play.
It looks great.
It runs beautifully
for 10 minutes.
And then this device
is going to get hot.
Device getting hot
means performance
will go down because phones
that explode generally,
are not perceived
well by clients.
So manufacturers have
to slow things down so
the device can cool down.
So your game that was running
at 30 frames per second
on the clock now is
running as 20, 15, 10.
And your customer will
go and play and write
to you and one star review.
One star reviews are bad.
I have an equation on my slide.
I know math.
Look at that.
Power consumption for a CPU
is equal to capacitance thingy
C. That thing is a constant
of some sort multiplied
by square of the voltage
multiplied by its frequency.
Now you see strings you can see
for each core the frequency.
Like value is like 2
gigahertz [INAUDIBLE]..
And you can see that thread
3 is basically maxing out
frequency on that core.
Also, in order to
run a max frequency,
the voltage has to go up as well
to maintain the tight timings
in the transistors.
At least, that's
what they told me
at the university 25 years ago.
But also notice this very
interesting phenomenon.
The frequency at
some point goes down,
because the scheduler decided
to lower the frequency.
But each core goes
down the same time.
You can see like one, two,
three, four times in a row.
They all go down at same time.
That means that by virtue
of having third three,
maxing out frequency
on one of the cores
and maxing out the voltage
on one of the cores--
voltage is squared.
It's consuming a lot of power.
It's forcing that small thread
n, to consume a lot of power
for a little bit of
work that most probably
doesn't need to run fast.
If that thing takes
10 times to run,
you would still hit 30 frame
per second most probably.
This phenomenon is clearer here.
This is a--
Snapdragon 855.
Yep, I remember correctly.
This has 2 and 1/2
clusters of course.
[INAUDIBLE] wants to
run at a lower clock?
Clock 2, three cores,
that run a higher clock.
And there's another
one, Clock 3,
that runs at even higher clock.
So basically, each
cluster has a clock plane.
And each cluster
is voltage gated.
That means that each cluster
runs the same voltage
and the same clock frequency,
except for Clock 3 that
can run at different
frequency from Clock 2.
Interestingly, even if it
runs at different frequency
from Clock 2, they still
share the same voltage,
which means if the voltage
goes up for the last CPU,
three more CPUs go up.
Everything consumes a
lot of power to run.
Big take away here.
Cores in a cluster always
share the same clock.
This doesn't make
me happy, because it
makes my life harder.
In yours as well.
On the other hand, it's
much simpler design.
And it's understandable why
all SOCs are designed this way.
No exception whatsoever.
This is another example.
This is very interesting
because CPUs 0, 1, 2,
and 3 are little course.
4, 5, 6, and 7 are big cores.
Now every SOC I've ever
seen has the first cores
as little cores with smaller
caches, lower frequencies.
And the last four
cores, big cores
or even bigger with larger
caches, higher frequency,
much faster and much
more power hungry.
They all look the
same, but please
still do your due
diligence and try
to understand the topology
of DSOC programmatically.
There are ways to do it.
We can talk about
it later in the game
reviews if you come over.
Look at that W. This
is another Unity game.
W is a worker thread.
All these worker threads are
running on CPU 4, 5, 6, or 7.
And little cores will
doing nothing, effectively.
This could be running
on a little cores,
consume much less power, and
give the big cores more chances
to go to sleep.
Going to sleep means
no power consumed.
It means lower temperature
in general, less chances
to throttle.
Less chances to go into
thermal throttle, less chances
to get the [INAUDIBLE] hot.
Because all forms,
sooner or later,
will overheat and
will be throttled.
And that's not under control.
You will not be told why.
You will not be told when.
Every device is different.
Every manufacturer has its own
secret sauce on how to do it.
It depends on the environment.
I mean, if you're
play in Finland,
you can probably for a while.
If you play in Italy, nope.
It's hot, in summer, especially.
You have to do everything in
your power, which means ship
as much as possible to
execute on little cores
in order to avoid
thermal throttling.
At the end of the day
distributor workloads,
which is very similar from
parallelizing workloads.
Going multi-threaded will help
you with thermal throttling
as well.
Which workload do you
want to run where?
Well, here's the thing.
High memory bandwidth,
you're reading a lot
from the system memory or you
need a lot of cache to go fast.
Well, this kind of workload
goes well on a big core.
You're doing a lot of math.
Well, lots of math
means big core again,
because have the
math instructions.
Little cores don't,
so they're much lower.
Everything else just
[INAUDIBLE] the little cores
and make me happy.
This is an
interesting statistic.
Well, it's not
statistics, it's numbers.
On a pixel 3, a little core
consumes 31 milli pair,
big core 215.
It's a seven times
ratio, which means
that if you have a piece of work
that you move to a little core,
if that piece of work takes
less than seven times,
the time to run when
compared to the big core,
you're saving power.
As long as you're running 30
frames per second, you're good.
That's the kind of memory model
that you have to think about.
On the latest devices,
this ratio goes up to 20.
Like it's 20 times
more power hungry.
And it's highly
unlikely that you're
going to see workload that runs
30 times faster on little core.
Keep it in mind.
Look at the [INAUDIBLE] thread.
Well, little cores
are doing nothing.
That goes straight into
a CPU 0, 1, 2, or 3.
And this is how you do it.
Set affinity.
It's just a system call.
It's pretty straightforward.
So here's some
code that I wrote.
I can claim I'm
a programmer now.
And it just runs a system
call and checks for errors.
This is like, super
straightforward.
And this is how you use it.
If I want to run
on a little core,
I set the mask to
the first core.
If I want to run
to the big cores,
I set the mask to
the last cores,
and then I set the
thread affinity.
Super straightforward.
Just give, do not pin a
thread to a certain core.
Just leave some room
for the scheduler
to do its work,
because it's good.
But pin to certain clusters.
And now we have only doing time.
We have 20 minutes left.
I have a volunteer here.
And I have my camera.
This has never been done
before at Google I/O.
Please, please, please,
please, please, come in.
I just volunteer you and I'm
going to take photos of him.
This has never been--
please be serious.
Like, do a more
developer-like face.
Like, a serious one,
more, more, more serious.
A little bit less serious.
Look at me.
Excellent, excellent.
[INAUDIBLE] Smile.
Excellent.
Thank you very much.
Didn't lose the-- did I lose
the thing, the clicker thing?
Did they give you
the clicker thing?
Do you have a clicking thing?
It's gone!
It's amazing!
I don't know.
It's gone!
Sorry?
No, it's gone!
Literally disappeared!
But we have another one.
Frame pacing is about a
lot about performance.
And in Systrace
you have this view,
which basically shows
you were Android
is latching on your
frame and displaying it.
That's basically
a very good proxy
for when my frame is going to
be on screen, when my user is
going to be seeing my image.
And if you see bars that
are not evenly spaced--
like, sometimes sorter,
sometimes bigger--
that is a sure sign your
having frame pacing issues.
This gets a little
bit more complicated.
Like the first bar
up there is when
your game is done with the
frame and is presenting it
to the system so it can be
grabbed and be displayed.
The second bar is a nice vsync
coming every 16.6 seconds,
60 frames per second.
Down there is the bar
that we saw before,
just a little bit the larger.
Shows you like, the
system is doing something.
It's sending the frame
to the outer compositor.
It's doing some work.
But the point is that
at some point when
the frame is present
in the queue,
Android will decide
OK, I gotta frame.
Off it goes to screen.
And it took about
50 milliseconds
in the first instance, because
look at the big circle there.
We miss the VSYNC.
We arrived slightly too
late with the VSYNC.
So Android had
nothing to display.
Then when there's
something to display,
Android was doing its work.
Immediately after the game
is presenting another frame--
so it is a typical example
of a game presenting as fast
as possible--
and then immediately
later Android says great,
I got the frame.
off it goes to screen
16 milliseconds later.
This translates when
you're playing into--
I'm running at 20
frame for per second.
And then I'm running a 60
and then 20 and then 60.
So the user perceive this
as choppy frame rate.
It's a choppy 60
frames per second.
One star review straight away.
It's very disturbing.
Generally speaking, a 60 frame
per second game that is choppy
is much worse than a
stable 30 frames per second
that is nice as move.
And that's how you
see it on Systrace.
But that's in largest one.
I'm slightly larger in the--
it's the same thing
that we showed before.
I'm just showing
you also the CPU.
And we can see that this frame,
which is like the big bar,
started a couple of milliseconds
too late after the VSYNC.
And it literally missed
by 100 microseconds.
It arrived slightly late
So Android will present
this frame 60 milliseconds
too late because we missed
by 100 microseconds.
We missed because we
started slightly too late.
Theoretically, this thread would
take less than 33 milliseconds
to process the frame.
This could run at 30 frame per
second, no problem whatsoever.
But it's not.
And it's not because
the game is too slow.
It's because it's
missing the frame pacing.
This is basically the cause
of most frame instabilities
that I've seen, because
as a game developer,
you know that if you want
to hit 30 frame per second,
you have to run a frame in
less than 33 milliseconds.
Most people do it
because they're good.
But then they don't
present at the right time
and the frame rate
is still choppy.
And you have frame
time stability.
But not only-- another issue
is imagine a touch input
that comes when the
first frame that takes 50
milliseconds to be displayed.
Well, this is going to be the
showed 60 milliseconds later.
So I touch and I see the
result of my touch 60
milliseconds too late.
And then I see the result
of I touch in the next frame
like, 60 milliseconds too early.
And this goes back and forth.
The brain is trained to expect
input at a certain [INAUDIBLE]..
If we just kept going back and
forth, it's a bad experience.
We do have a solution.
It's called Android
frame pacing API.
Tian mentioned it before.
This is a bunch of code that
doesn't live inside of Android.
It lives as a library and you
can download it and try it.
It supports several
case scenarios,
and it's very easy to integrate.
And basically what it does
is there's an innate--
there's a swap, and there's
a set a bunch of parameters.
And from there on,
it will take care
of making sure that your frame
is nicely presented right
before the VSYNC.
And also it will give
you back callbacks
that you can use to
start your game logic
right on time in the VSYNC.
You put the two things together.
As long as you are running in
less than 30 milliseconds, 33,
you're good.
You will be frame
paced perfectly
at 30 frames per second.
And that's all done by us.
You don't have to
care about what
kinds of devices,
because devices is likely
different in the way
they treat the VSYNC
and they treat the logic.
You just don't have
to care about it.
Set your frame
interval as you're
used to and all because it's
available for both Vulcan
and Open GL.
This is the [INAUDIBLE].
It's innate, set
at swap interval,
and then at some point
in the future, swap.
When you swap, swap will return
and it will be presented.
And then you will
have a callback.
And you can start your
game logic straight away
at the next VSYNC.
It also comes with
auto mode, which
is kind of a peculiar
mode to run in.
There are situations
where imagine your game
is running on a device
as not as performant.
So it mostly hits 30
frames per second,
but sometimes it slows
down on heavy scene
and runs at 20 frame per second.
Well, in the case that
we just saw earlier,
all the framework come
at 50 frame per second.
Then the second one
would probably be at 16
because I arrived like, late.
But then I present another one.
Maybe it's going to be at 33.
I don't know.
It's going to be as
fast as possible.
But the framework
will be choppy.
Auto mode detects this
condition and says good.
You're running at a stable 20.
You're not hitting a stable 30?
Well, I'm going to slowing
down for the time being.
You can reset at any time.
But when the frame
rate goes back
to a more stable 30
frame per second,
auto mode will
bump you up again.
It has the very good
consequence that you are also
going to save battery, because
it will take certain frames
and will just slow
them down, just
introduce weightings, which
means CPUs and GPUs will have
more chances to go to sleep.
That's how 30 frames
per second looks like.
This is a stable pacing.
Now if you come
over there, we can
show you the frame basic
API on one of the devices.
We can go more in-depth.
Last but not least,
this is a fun one
because you have phones that
are packed with four megapixels
today.
And many games make
sure that they're
going to shape each megapixel,
each pixel in the megapixel.
Four megapixel, for reference,
is twice give or take,
a full HD resolution, which
probably a year ago was
state of the art
console like, rendering
sent to a 55-inch display.
And there was like, awesome.
This is a great looking game.
It runs at full HD.
When I was working on
console, I was running a 720.
720 is one megapixel.
Now phones, we have four
megapixel packed there.
You do not need to
shade all of them.
Please don't.
Because that's so
I feel about it.
How do you recognize
that you are probably
shading too many pixels?
Well, you're going to
be GPU-bound, likely.
In SysTrace there is a bar that
gives you the buffer count.
Buffer count means that the
CPU is presenting a frame.
Buffer count goes to one.
The GPU does its own thing,
just shade every single pixel.
Then the CPU is doing its
work for the next frame.
And if the GPU
isn't finished yet,
well, the CPU will just put
another buffer in the field,
just ready, good to go.
And then wait, most probably.
And the GPU will
just try to catch up.
Well, that's a situation where
this buffer count goes back
to two.
Another way of
saying it is well,
I have a frame that is
presented in 50 milliseconds.
Let's assume we don't have
any frame pacing issue here.
We already solved it.
Well, but my frame time
is taking 40 milliseconds.
Where the rest of the time
is spent most probably,
is going to be spent
shading all four megapixel.
This is very straightforward
to find out in Systrace.
I've seen a bunch looking
exactly like this.
Now here's how you solve it.
Instead of a 3K by
1440 display, instead
of rendering to all of it,
well, create a render target
that is smaller.
And make sure that you only
stretch in one direction.
Reason is when you
interpolate back,
it's going to be much
higher quality and much more
cache [INAUDIBLE].
And make sure that your
only rendering your gain
word into this
smaller render target.
Not your UI.
The UI has generally thin things
and thin lines and phones.
They don't scale well just
rendering at full resolution.
UIs, except for some cases,
tend not to be too heavy.
So they can go at
full resolution
and then composite the two.
In this case, you're
saving 58% of the pixels.
This is going to be roughly
a full HD still on a smaller
screen.
It's going to look amazing.
It's going to look great.
Nobody's going to see it.
If your artists think
that they're going to see
the difference, just tell
them that they won't.
If they still
insist, use my trick.
I never told artists
that I was doing
any of these optimizations.
And they never spotted me.
That's why I'm still here.
If they spotted me,
I probably wouldn't--
my artists were awfully mean.
To do the resize,
it cost some time.
It's got some GPU time because
you have to interpolate back
to full screen for
the final presentation
and final compositing.
And every Android device
has an hardware composer
that is not exposed to
the user, which doesn't
make me particularly happy.
On the other hand, any game that
would probably use this kind
of techniques and will probably
be GPU bound has some kind
of post-processing and
tone mapping at the end,
where you're doing--
I don't know-- some
kind of blooming
some kind of color correction.
Well, you can do the
process of stretching back
to full resolution in
the post-processing step.
It comes out not for free
because nothing is free,
but it's a nice way
to hide the time
and to use it for
something useful.
This is a pretty common way
of doing the stretching back.
The important thing-- and I
want to stress this point,
is that please stretch
only one direction.
Do not resize in two directions.
The quality is much higher if
you do it in one direction.
We've seen these
four big, I would
say, performance pitfalls.
And I showed you various
ways to tackle it.
Now you have a better
knowledge of what
you can encounter in the
field, and a better knowledge
of how to solve these issues.
They're pretty easy
at the end of the day,
except probably the last one.
It doesn't take long
to implement it.
And use this knowledge now.
Please go there and
make some great games.
My name is Francesco Carucci.
[MUSIC PLAYING]